un petit à quel point compte elle cette
étape
ukrainienne juste avant celle en Pologne
demain vous le disiez tout à l'heure
moment très important à plusieurs à
plusieurs égards un message adressé au
Russe un message aussi de soutien aux
Européens aux Ukrainiens et puis un
message au Polonais aussi oui mais ça je
polonais parce que vous avez bien vu on
voit depuis début de cette agression
celle de 2022 il y a aussi celle de 2014
faut pas l'oublier mais on voit bien que
un certain nombre de pays qui était
autrefois dans l'orbite soviétique sont
extrêmement parce qu'ils connaissent la
musique si vous permettez cette
expression sont extrêmement remontés et
sont Davis que les choses doivent être
ferme pour autant pour autant sont-ils
partisans d'une défense européenne non
ce sont des pays qui s'en sont toujours
remis comme la Pologne au parapluie
américain et pour la Pologne est très
important d'avoir le soutien des
américain parce que pour eux tout ce qui
relève vrai éventuellement d'une défense
européenne d'abord c'est pas pour tout
de suite et en plus ça serait quelque
chose qui serait un peu finalement une
construction trop compliquée donc il y a
ça effectivement de la part de Biden
c'est rassuré les Polonais vous il y a
des choses très alarmistes dans la
presse polonaise en ce moment sur le
fait que si jamais l'Ukraine lâcher ou
perdait la partie et bien ça serait les
Polonais qui seraient au premier loge
pour la suite et d'ailleurs
régulièrement vous avez les
propagandistes les les fantôches de
Poutine qui à la télévision publique
russe disent régulièrement après tout la
prochaine étape c'est Varsovie bon alors
il faut faire la part du de la
redomontade et de et des en fait des des
vantardises des uns et des autres mais
c'est quand même ça pour Varsovie qui
prend très au sérieux ce type de
discours alors sur le fond moi je suis
pleinement d'accord accès à 10 marques
c'est vrai que on a rien à se mettre de
nouveau sous la dent
qui plus est des choses qui sont
peut-être même un peu
fallacieuses quand Joe Biden dit nous
allons continuer à finalement ruiner
l'économie russe écoutez l'économie
russe elle est pas si ruinée que ça ces
derniers temps il y a même des
prévisions de croissance qui ne sont pas
évidemment extraordinaires mais qui
existe quand même ça veut dire que la
Russie par des moyens détournés et
parvenu à contourner l'embargo et même à
s'enrichir puisque le gaz est devenu
plus cher et qu'ils ont produisent moins
donc là il faut il faut voir ce que
peuvent être ces sanctions dans le
détail parce que celles qui ont été
annoncées et auxquelles on a procédé
depuis un an ne sont pas toutes d'une
efficacité redoutable et puis alors
évidemment la question des armes alors
ça on en a parlé la question notamment
des des F-16 des avions là il n'y en a
pas été directement question mais l'idée
c'est quoi c'est c'est toujours la même
contradiction que faut-il faire faut-il
maintenir l'Ukraine à niveau
de la Russie pour qu'elle s'effondre pas
ou bien lui donner un avantage pour
qu'elle puisse au moins repousser les
troupes de Poutine hors du crâne c'est
ça la question et ce que craint
l'Occident c'est que si évidemment il y
a cette aide qui permet aux Ukrainiens
de repousser de bouter les troupes
russes hors du Crès cela signifie pour
Moscou à une cobellie gérance et donc le
signe d'une escalade on en est toujours
là et d'une certaine manière quand les
deux hommes parlent de ce qui est de la
démocratie de ce que sont les valeurs
effectivement c'est important c'est même
capital mais que voulez-vous faire et
c'est la question autour de laquelle on
ne peut pas éternellement tourner que
voulez-vous faire quand la Russie est
conduite par un homme comme Poutine par
un groupe comme celui de footing comme
une administration comme celle de
Poutine c'est là toute la question et le
président français ne fait pas exception
à la chose quand il contourne lui aussi
en disant il ne faut pas écraser la
Russie tout à fait d'accord mais alors
qu'il faut il écraser pour que réussi
comprennent non seulement ce qu'elle
fait mais ce qu'elle vit aussi puisque
d'une certaine manière enfin même
sûrement Poutine est à la fois un
dictateur pour le monde mais aussi pour
ses propres concitoyens